Thanks to the work of some very fine dramatists,
the Netflix adaptation of the Series of Unfortunate
Events novels has been absolutely fantastic,
a word which here means full of very frightening
danger, various fakery disguises, and very
fitting definitions.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and today,
I'm exploring 12 of the biggest differences
between the Unfortunate Events TV series and
the original books.
Spoilers ahead for the show and novels.
While the books are rather cryptic about the
identity of the taxi driver who offers to
take the Baudelaires away from the Hotel Denouement
after Dewey's death by harpoon, the TV show
is much, much clearer.
"Violet, Klaus, and Sunny Baudelaire."
"My name is Lemony Snicket."
In the novels, the children couldn't see the
taxi driver's face in the darkness, just the
tip of a lit cigarette.
Of course, even before season 3, Lemony was
already more involved and present in the action
of the Netflix series compared to the books.
"when we hear Uncle Monty tell the children..."
"I promise you, no harm will come to you in
the Reptile Room."
"... we should be on guard for the unpleasant
arrival of dramatic irony."
But it was great to finally see the Baudelaires
and our narrator meet in the Penultimate Peril
episodes.
The whole cast has been a joy to watch throughout
the series, with Patrick Warburton fantastic
as Lemony Snicket, perfectly capturing his
deadpan nature.
One character who doesn't make it from the
books into the TV show is Captain Widdershins.
In Season 3, we just see a prominently placed
portrait of him as well as a photograph belonging
to his step-daughter Fiona, who reveals that
Widdershins left one day to answer a distress
call from a manatee and never came back.
The TV series combines parts of Fiona's character
from the Grim Grotto book with aspects of
her step-father's role as Captain of the Queequeg.
We do hear Widdershins' voice in the finale,
showing that he is indeed still alive!
Netflix makes several more changes to the
Grim Grotto storyline, for example, Olaf finds
the Queequeg earlier in the show than he does
in the books, and he forces the Baudelaires
to visit the Gorgonian Grotto, whereas in
the books, he turns up after the orphans return
from the Grotto with Fiona, who doesn't accompany
them there in the TV show.
And in the books, Phil goes missing part way
through the story along with Captain Widdershins.
The show also reveals how the Hook-Handed
Man, aka Fernald, lost both his hands, which
isn't confirmed in the novels, though it has
been a fan theory.
I suspect these various changes were made
to condense the action, highlight the Baudelaires'
self-reliance by removing an adult guardian
figure, as well as give fans some closure
on their theories.
Because the show's writers wanted Count Olaf
to end Season 2 and begin Season 3 on a triumphant
note, they decided to keep his villainous
associates alive even though several of them
are killed off earlier in the books.
For example, in the novels, the Henchperson
of Indeterminate Gender is last seen at Heimlich
Hospital where they likely died in the fire,
and the Bald Man is eaten alive by lions in
The Carnivorous Carnival book.
In the TV show, however, both those henchpeople
are still part of Olaf's troupe throughout
The Slippery Slope episodes.
As for the White-Faced Women, on the Netflix
series they abandon Olaf's troupe, after he
tells them to throw Sunny off the mountain,
as he also did in the tenth novel.
However, in a change from the book, the Bald
Man and The Henchperson of Indeterminate Gender
join the White-Faced Women in quitting Olaf's
team, and, as they leave, they discuss their
future plans which involve farming and music
halls.
We last see them on stage together at the
end of a show they've put on, enjoying the
audience's applause.
Unlike the members of Olaf's villainous theatre
troupe, the Carnival Freaks last a lot less
time in the TV series than they do in the
books.
In the original stories, Colette, Hugo, and
Kevin are still alive and kicking and very
much part of Olaf's wicked crew at the Hotel
Denouement and they even provide evidence
at Olaf and the Baudelaire's trial, though
it's unclear whether they make it out of the
hotel fire alive.
However, in the TV adaptation, the former
carnival employees are bumped off in the Mortmain
Mountains by the Man With A Beard But No Hair
and the Woman With Hair But No Beard, soon
after the start of Season 3.
I imagine this was done to gradually chip
away at Olaf and his schemes, bringing him
down from his literal and figurative highest
point at the start of the Season.
And, of course, it also gives us some insight
into the show's two newest villains.
During Season 3, we also learn more than we
do in the books about Count Olaf's relationship
to the Man With A Beard But No Hair and the
Woman With Hair But No Beard.
When Olaf first sees the ominous duo in the
TV show, he calls them 'mummy' and 'daddy'.
Obviously, we see Olaf's actual father during
the opera flashbacks, so these two terrible
people are not his real parents, but rather
his figurative parents or mentors, who recruited
him to their nefarious ranks when he was at
a low point in his life, after the death of
his father.
By adding some backstory between these two
new characters and Olaf in the show, it gives
us some extra context as to what led him down
this dark, fire-filled path in life.
And it's interesting to see how this man and
woman are so much more impressed with Esmé,
who they've not met before, than they are
with Olaf, who's so desperate for their approval.
The TV series leaves the Quagmires and the
Widdershins on a somewhat hopeful note, with
the Quagmires finally reuniting; and Fiona
and Fernald finding their stepfather, Captain
Widdershins.
However, the books leave us on a much vaguer
and less optimistic note when it comes to
their fates.
In the novels, Quigley does reunite with his
siblings and helps them deal with the eagles
sent to attack their self-sustaining hot-air
mobile home, but the birds manage to pop the
balloons, sending everyone crashing into the
Queequeg below, which wrecks the submarine.
The Widdershins and Kit Snicket, who was on
the sub at the time, are all tossed into the
sea, along with the Quagmires and Hector from
the Village of Fowl Devotees.
Then the Great Unknown appears, and all of
them, apart from Kit, disappear, "either swallowed
up or rescued by that mysterious thing".
The way the TV show ends the Quagmires and
Widdershins' stories gives fans a little more
closure, which many have enjoyed, though some
prefer a more unfortunate ending like the
books.
In the TV version of events, when a heavily-pregnant
Beatrice and her husband Bertrand decide to
leave the Island, it's because they choose
to return home in time for the birth of their
first child, Violet, as they realise they
can't shelter their family there forever.
This is rather different from the books where
the couple are forced to abandon the Island
after Ishmael arrives and begins spreading
fears among the islanders about Beatrice and
Bertrand's leadership.
Ishmael's background as the founder of VFD
and Principal of Prufrock Prep is also new
to the series, as in the books, he's simply
a former member of VFD and chemistry teacher.
These changes were likely made because there's
just one episode to wrap up the whole story,
and the mutiny against the Baudelaire parents
would have needed more build-up to make sense.
As for Ishmael's new backstory, well, that's
very much in keeping with the TV series which
has been dropping clues and adding intriguing
storylines about VFD since the beginning.
By the way, I explain a lot more about the
TV show's ending, including the Sugar Bowl,
VFD, the Schism, and much more in my Ending
Explained video.
You can tap in the top right to watch that
or click the link in the video description.
Instead of bringing the third and final season
to a close with Violet, Klaus, Sunny and baby
Beatrice sailing away from the island, leaving
their fate ambiguous, as happens in Chapter
14 of the last Unfortunate Events book; the
Netflix series continues past this point,
skipping ahead ten or so years, and shows
Lemony Snicket receiving a letter from his
niece, Beatrice Baudelaire the Second, and
meeting up with her at a soda bar where she
tells him what happened to the Baudelaires
after they left the island.
By continuing the story like this, the TV
show is taking a page out of another of Lemony
Snicket's books called The Beatrice Letters,
which, as well as correspondence between Lemony
and the Baudelaires' mother, also contains
letters from Kit's daughter Beatrice, asking
Lemony for help tracking down Violet, Klaus,
and Sunny [as they've become separated at
some point].
Now, what did you think of the changes in
the TV series?
And what are your favourite moments in the
show and the books?
Let me know in the comments below!
If you enjoyed this, smash that subscribe
button and notification bell so you don't
miss any new videos.
Next up, tap left for a full breakdown of
Season 3 including the Sugar Bowl and VFD,
or tap right for another video you're sure
to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!